في جلسه مجلس الامن الدوليه التي خصصت
لمناقشه تداعيات انسحاب روسيا من اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب حذرت روزمارين دي كارلو
وكيله الامين العام للمتحده للشؤون
السياسيه حضرت من خطر حدوث نزاع نتيجه
لحادث عسكري في البحر الاسود
وقالت دي كارلو ان تهديدات باستهداف سفن
مدنيه في مياه البحر الاسود غير مقبوله
واشارت الى ان قصف الموانئ يتعارض مع
التزامات روسيا ببوج بمذكره التفاهم مع
الامم المتحده من جانبيه قال مارتن
جرافيتر وكيلو الامين العام للامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه الى مبادره البحر الاسود
تحت التصدير الامن ل 33 مليون طن من
الغذاء لخمس واربعين دوله وحذرا من ارتفاع
اسعار الحبوب العربيه والتي قد يدفع
ملايين الاشخاص الى الجوع
كما قال الامين العام يمكن لتدمير البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه للموانئ الاوكرانيه ان
يرقى الى مستوى انتهاك للحقوق الانسانيه
الدوليه وخلاصه القول ان صادرات الاغذيه
والاسمده من اوكرانيا وروسيا لا تزال
تكتسي اهميه قصوى لضمان الامن الغذائي
العالمي لذا ستستمر الامم المتحده في
تعاونها مع جميع الجهات المعنيه لنضمن
وصول الاغذيه والاسمده الاوكرانيه
والروسيه الى الاسواق العالميه علينا ايضا
ان نضمن انخفاض الاسعار وتعزيز الامن
الغذائي في العالم اننا بحاجه الى دعم
دولي متحد
المندوبه الامريكيه في جلسه مجلس الامن
قالت ان روسيا تصدر الانا الحبوب اكثر من
اي وقت مضى وباسعار اعلى وحضرت من توسيع
روسيا هجماتها لتشمل السفن البدنيه بالبحر
الاسود وقالت انه لم يفت الاوان لم يفزع
الاوان بعد
لتراجع موسكو عن قرارها وتمديد مبادره
الحبوب وتنفيذها
الاوكرانيه قتلت مزيدا من المدنيين ودمرت
60 الف طنين من الحبوب هذه كميه كافيه
لاطعام اكثر من 270 الف شخص على مدى عام
كامل هذا الاسبوع اعلنت روسيا ان كل السفن
في البحر الاسود سيتم التعامل معها على
انها يمكن ان تحمل شحنات عسكريه الليله
الماضيه لوحدها شنت روسيا جوله جديده من
الهجمات على اودستا روسيا تشن حربا على
امدادات الغذاء في العالم
في الجلسه قال ان بلاده ليس ضد صفقه
الحبوب وهي مستعده لبحث امكانيه الانضمام
اليها ولكن في حاله
استيفاء الشروط معينه حسب تعبيرهم وطلب
نائب المندوب الروسي خلال جلسه مجلس الامن
برفع حقيقي وليس نظريا للعقوبات على
امدادات الحبوب والاسمده الروسيه بالاسواق
العالميه واوضح ان بلاده لفتت الانتباه من
قبل الى ان مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود لم
تعد تعكس الهدف الاوليه واصبحت ذات طبيعه
تجاريه
من مجلس الامن في نيويورك قرص الجزيره
مراد هاشم مراد الكلمات التي القيت عديده
وكثيره ولكن ما الهدف من عقد هذه الجلسه
بالدرجه الاولى
مرحبا جمال الداعون لهذه الجلسه هم فرنسا
والاكوادور
والبلدان تنتقدان روسيا على انسحابها من
مبادره الحبوب بطبيعه الحال هي الجلسه
الثانيه في هذا الموضوع خلال هذا الاسبوع
اغلب الكلمات التي سمعناها بما في ذلك
الاحاطات المقدمه نيابه عن الامانه العامه
للامم المتحده من وكيل الامين العام
للشؤون السياسيه ووكيله الامين العام
وكيله الامين العام للشؤون السياسيه ووكيل
الامين العام للشؤون الانسانيه
مجملها في الواقع
حمله نبره
انتقاد او ادانه او لوم على درجات تفاوت
لانسحاب روسيا من هذه المبادره اللافت في
مداخله روسيا هو تاكيد نائب المندوب
الروسي
على ان بلاده لا تعترض على هذه المبادره
وترى انها مهمه للعديد من الدول وانه يمكن
اعاده النظر فيها وفي قرار الانسحاب منها
اذا لببت
الشروط الروسيه وهو ذكر اضافه الى رفع
الجزاءات ايضا
الزراعيه اضافه الى اضافه الى ذلك اعاده
الارتباط بنظام السويفت فيما يتعلق بالبنك
الزراعي الروسي وايضا ازاله العقبات امام
استيراد قطع الغيار للمعدات والالات
الزراعيه التي قال انها ان اسعارها تضاعفت
بنسبه 40 في المئه وايضا ازاله العوائق
العواق امام التاجير عمليه التاجير
والتامين على النقل ايضا
استعاده العمل بخط انابيب نقل الامونيا
الى اوديسا ايضا قال فيما يتعلق بضروره
الاستعاده الطابع الانساني لهذه المبادره
اذ ان روسيا تعتبر ان ان الطابعه التجاري
انها انها تحمل طابعا تجاريا ليس الا كما
طبقت خلال الفتره الماضيه حينما اشار الى
ان 70% من الصادرات بموجب هذه المبادره
ذهبت الى دول غنيه او متوسطه الدخل في
مقابل نسبه بسيطه جدا للدول الناميه
بطبيعه الحال كانت وايضا تكراره لتحذير
السفن من الاتجاه للموانع الاوكرانيه
وانها ستعتبر اهدافا معاديه القاه اللوم
على الدول الغربيه اذا فشل تطبيق هذه
المبادره جمال شكرا لك مراد هاشم مراسل
الجزيره متحدثا الينا من مجلس الامن في ني